from the super bowl just a couple of
years ago to number 23 on the pft
pre-season power rankings what idiot put
them at number 23 well it was me
and somebody had to be number 23. look
chris i feel like the sun has set
quickly i know you do what the rams put
together on what got the rams to the
super bowl what got the rams into a game
where frankly if jared goff sees
brandon cooks a little bit sooner and
delivers the football accurately and the
rams go up seven to three late in the
third quarter they may have won
the super bowl two years in a row nfc
west quarterbacks with championship
throws that don't make them and jared
goff making a ton of money one of the
reasons why they've had to shed some
players to accommodate jared goff's
gigantic cap number there's a lot of
changes a lot of change there is this
year for the rams todd gurley gone
brandon cook's gone eric weddle gone
clay matthew's gone dante fowler gone
yeah greg zurline gone wade phillips
corey littleton middle linebacker corey
littleton gone wade phillips
gone
wade phillips one of the one of the main
reasons why we had faith in sean mcvay
taking over this rams team and being
completely focused on the offense
remember his first year on the job when
the defense was on the field he was
sitting on a cooler right getting ready
for the getting the plays ready for the
next drive he could hand the keys to
wade phillips now wade phillips out of
football these are major changes
for the rams who are going to look very
different with these uniforms and i'm
not all that thrilled about but the
changes to the team it puts more
pressure on sean mcvay
and i i just i look
if you have more faith than i do in
jared goff you're not as concerned about
these changes i think you take todd
gurley out of the mix that offense is
very different you take brandon cooks
out of the mix that offense is very
different it's going to be a lot on
jared goff this year and i just i just i
wonder if the organization realizes that
well i i mean i i think they do i would
think so it was an underwhelming year
last year for jared goff i mean the rams
are a fascinating team they really are
and you know mike i would say
you know it was probably it's probably
the first team on your power rankings
that i looked at and i went ooh i just
think that's a little low and i
understand it and maybe i'm wrong so
just hear me out here now certainly
there's a lot of questions here the team
is kind of in this re semi rebuild
they're trying to retool without
rebuilding i guess we should say now i
think the first thing is
the coaches that you hit on you know yes
mcvay the nfl caught up to his offense
towards the end of that super bowl year
and it kind of carried into last year
and i think that's why you're seeing
some you know he made some changes there
as far as some of the offensive minds
around him and i think he's going to
have to or hoping that he's going to
reinvent and i've heard that he is doing
that he's toying with a lot of different
stuff to you know
put into his offense this year so
that'll be interesting because i am i do
think they need to change up their
personnel sets and what they do a little
then on the field you're right there's a
lot of moving pieces here but i still
look at this team and go damn there's
still a lot of talented football players
on it yeah you lose brandon cooks but
still got robert woods and cooper cup
who are both thousand yard receivers two
pretty good tight ends you know
offensive line certainly a question mark
and we'll see because you know that that
does affect jared goff jared goff is not
the best in a pocket with pressure
around him and he's not the most mobile
guy either you know and then have some
difference makers on the defensive side
mike so that's where i'm like torn
between them because you're right
there's a lot of new pieces there's an
o-line that i'm not sure about but then
i started talking about defense and you
started going aaron donald michael
brockers jalen ramsey you know leonard
floyd and you start going through some
of the names you go damn there's some
players out there that can influence a
game so uh i that they had they are a
very interesting team this year and you
know their battle tough and i'm just i
don't know where it's gonna go but i
guess i'm a little more hopeful than you
are at this point i guess is what i'm
saying
you mentioned cooper cup and robert
woods and there were two games that
brandon cooks missed last year with the
rams after he suffered a concussion i
think against the bengals in london i
want to go back and look more carefully
at what the offense did without him on
the field because one of the reasons
that cup and woods may be doing so well
is the presence of brandon cooks who was
summarily traded to the houston texans
part of their effort to replace deandre
hopkins chris one of the reasons i put
the rams at number 23 yeah is the
division they're in yeah you put the
rams in the nfc east they're not 23. you
put the rams in the afc south they're
not 23. but the rams are stuck with the
49ers and it seems like everybody wants
to try to imitate the 49ers now and it
feels like that's what sean mcvay's at
least going to do with this running game
where it's not going to go through one
guy they're going to have three or four
guys who share the load you've got the
seahawks you've got the cardinals who i
have pegged to make a jump this year so
somebody's getting left in the dust
and
between and now look we know injuries
coveted 19 all sorts of circumstances
can affect this but you look at 49er
seahawks cardinals rams to me the team
most likely to be left in the dust is
the rams and that's why they're at
number 23. yeah i mean listen i i'm not
going to sit here and say that that
logic is stupid or anything like that
yeah i i hear you you're right i'm going
to put them third i am too i'm not going
to put them forth i'm not going to put
arizona over the los angeles rams yet a
team that was on the verge of the
playoffs again last year and like i said
been in some big tough physical football
games and i just have too much
confidence in a sean mcvet you know in
his career in la there's only been one
game where i felt like man his team kind
of got overwhelmed and you know
run out the gym and that was that
baltimore game last year i think that
was on a thursday night when the ravens
came out to la or maybe it was a monday
night um but but what about the
buccaneers what about when the
buccaneers just flat out torch well yeah
earlier that year they were having a lot
of issues yeah they let up a lot of big
plays right jared goff made a lot of big
plays in that game but had some bad
turnovers early that put them in the
hole and do those things but yeah you
know
listen they had some moments last year
but at the same time they were there in
position to
be in the playoffs come december even
though it wasn't the most impressive
year we've seen so i guess what i look
at more than anything and i just go
there's things to like when you go okay
mcveigh kid genius luster's worn off a
little but damn still a really damn
awesome good coach and then you know you
talk about a stable of running backs
that's unproven but i think has some
talent we'll see the receivers tight
ends like we talked about pretty good
and then you talk about a front seven on
defense with a guy like jalen ramsey in
the back the back end and a joe johnson
at safety and i just look at him and go
man there's some difference makers there
they can be a pain in the butt they got
some players who will be able to
influence games just by their individual
play and that's where i think the rams
are intriguing they got a very you know
i don't know mike what do you think
what's their ceiling what's the ceiling
for the rams in your mind
i would say that
they i don't think they can win the
division i think the five seed would be
their ceiling if everything falls
together but even then do you envision
them boxing out either the 49ers at the
seahawks this year now look not
everybody's going to be what they were
last year that's one of the hard parts
when it comes to right predicting what's
going to happen in a given season but i
think it's going to be hard for them
they would have been the seventh seed
last year if there had been a seventh
seed they came on strong late and gave
the vikings a run for the sixth seed
i i think that that i'll say
i'll say five seed is their absolute
best case scenario i don't see them
winning that division no so the five
seed second place in the division top
wild card in the nfc i think that's
their best hope this year yeah okay i'm
i'm with you there i think that's the
way i look at it too they could be a an
11 and 5 5 seed or 10 and 6 5 seed
something like that you know the floor i
don't look at that being too too low
either you know i don't know where you
think there but i i mean
man i maybe uh i'm gonna s you know six
and ten seven and nine something like
that but i do think you bring up a very
interesting point too mike you know we
always talk about the start of the
schedule and man the rams yeah with some
of these moving pieces and maybe trying
some new schemes and things like that
you got to go you got the cowboys to
open up and then you go to philadelphia
and two buffalo two east coast trips you
know that's going to tell us a lot about
that team and where that season's going
right after three weeks really
and the league doesn't want them to stay
there in between the league wants them
to come back so you know whether it's
the 49ers the rams any of these west
coast teams that had back-to-back road
games and thought they were going to set
up shop somewhere in the east coast
that's not going to happen chris here's
the thing that benefits though the rams
four games against the nfc east four
games against the afc east and we've
talked about this before with three wild
card berths now someday
four teams from one division will make
it to the playoffs and that's not an
impossibility this year for the rams
given their out of division schedule
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports